we're driving out to Long Island today
because we found out there's a man out
there who legally changed his name to
Santa Claus so yeah we're gonna go
interview Santa it turns out this Santa
is not so traditional
I Drive the a black Dodge pickup truck
with vanity plates oh yes I have vanity
plates it says Santa's sleigh before he
was Santa
he was Frank was born in Brooklyn but we
lived here on Long Island I have been
married 23 years now so how do you tell
your wife that you're changing your name
to Santa Claus she said as long as I
don't have to change my name
go right ahead Santa has been Santa for
almost two decades and he's good at it
I'm probably on and this is not an
exaggeration thousands of refrigerators
he's got the laughs you know that's
that's my Santa laughs the suit
I design my food but here are some other
things about Santa that might surprise
you
I have three tattoos on me of me I'm
very into zombies I love barbecue I have
a smoker it can fit 150 pounds of meat
it you've got this tiki hut and
above-ground saltwater pool in his
backyard yes I'm that extreme when it
comes to my idea of relaxation so
there's a little Frank left in there but
no question he's fully committed to
being Santa I want to look like the poem
says I'm the most loved person on the
planet we totally met Santa